i opened for larry david years ago when
he was a stand-up what was his stand-up
like brilliant and impossible i was the
emc actually they told me you have to
watch this guy's whole set a lot of
times he won't finish his set because he
gets angry and i didn't know anything
about him i never heard of him the
audiences didn't know what to do with
him i would be quietly ordering beer and
he'd go how could you be so rude what
kind of person you need to start
screaming at them and he throw money at
people take your money back and leave
you
he just gets so angry one night he
really bombed and the crowd was great
they were like the best crowd we'd ever
seen and after the show he said what did
you think of that crowd they were awful
weren't they were they awful they were
rude and just noisy and bad and it
wasn't true but i said yeah yeah guys
just being polite he goes well why don't
you do something about you're the host
you're supposed to know
yeah i auditioned for the show once and
he said i remember you i remember i
didn't recount to him all right how
impossible he was
i just said yeah yeah cause i was trying
to get a job